all right I'll Sandra we had a chance to
really dig into the new endgame of
division 2 which is supposed to be a
better version than the first time
around during the event they actually
mentioned a few times that they knew
they sort of botched it and they want to
make sure they got it you know this time
around for the sequel
so here's we're gonna do we're gonna
talk about the impact of the factions on
the map we're gonna talk about kind of
how that ties into specialized weapons
and bullets sponginess and settlements
how that all ties into the faction
system and what you can do there then
what kind of end with some things we
didn't like because we don't want to
just say everything's amazing with the
vision it's definitely got some of the
original division problems
all right so why are factions different
this time around from the first game for
this one the I guess the starting back
ssin is the the hyenas gradually over
the course of the forty hour apparently
40 hour campaign you'll see more like
factions sort of step things up there's
gonna be an endgame faction they
actually invade pretty much every
mission that you know you play during
the campaign so every single mission the
particular the two we played those were
the grand you know Washington hotel and
you know the Jefferson Trade Center and
if you try those again during the
endgame the particularly the invaded
mission sort of variant of that mission
the black tusk will replace the faction
that was there previously one of the
things that sets them apart from the
other one the other factions rather is
that um they can use all the same skills
that uh you know you guys that we have
actually so they have drones they
actually have these these are really
weird like you know walking like robots
that look like something that right out
of like Boston dynamic videos and
they're equally they're equally as scary
and just off-putting and you know the it
really like you know had us just sort of
scrambling you know trying to figure out
like a good vantage point to try to take
it out you're kind of getting at
something that was interesting with the
the new faction invading which is that
over the past couple demos that we've
played you and I have played three dark
zones we played some at e3 it always
felt like the specializations didn't
have any meeting so specializations are
the sniper rifle the grenade launcher or
the crossbow and then they said there's
going to be another one
you know they actually said I believe
three new specializations will
eventually be added into the game at a
later point not edy launch and we never
really figured out what those were for
because honestly they didn't seem all
that different their normalized in
regular PvP and their normalized in the
dark zone so they don't really seem all
that useful so it turns out we found it
at this event that the black tusk
invasion makes everything incredibly
difficult oh yeah and those
specializations become critical to your
success we played through two missions
we played one really excellent one
called the Air and Space Museum yeah
which takes place in the Air and Space
Museum in Washington and the other one
was a bunker which we didn't get into
later it wasn't as good yeah but it was
critical that people were picking up and
using their special weapons during the
endgame invaded missions but the thing
is I get to balance it out is that the
ammo drops for these specializations are
really rare like you know and a lot more
rare in like cases like in destiny to
where you know the heavy ammo drops like
it comes up but not so often where you
can just keep taking advantage of it so
when you have it you got to make sure
you use it at the right time and you
know you don't waste it
a good example of what you're talking
about are some of the heavier units you
know this kind of plays back into the
conversation where some people don't
like the bullet sponginess of it it's a
it's a modern shooter and it feels a
little bit weird yeah to dump entire
clips into people who are unarmored so
some of the units that we saw do have
armor and it was it seemed like it made
a lot more sense and that you actually
had to break their armor yeah before you
could even start hurting them and once
you broke their armor some of them would
go down very easily with a head shot
yeah the bullet sponginess is the game
it's still there but there's more
situations in which it it makes sense
the one in particular that I think a lot
that really stood out for a lot of us
was the one carrying like the heavy
Gatling gun and he's wearing like power
armor that looks like just like straight
out of like fallout and as soon as I
just saw him pop up I was like okay this
is this is that kind of flight so if you
go for head shots and you know
eventually you'll be able to break his
helmet and you know going for the chest
will you know disintegrate the armor and
that will of course lead up and to you
know actually cause him like raw damage
thing to that elite
let's talk about the open world because
we had a chance to run around the open
world from what they described and it
from what we saw it seems like this is
the case but it's a little bit more like
GTA san andreas now where factions
actually fight for control of the map
and also control points and you as a
player can fight for these control
points in addition to bolstering
settlements around the map what you have
real people this time by the way it's
not just echoes and you can actually
talk to these people and it also ties it
back into the sort of the broader like a
sort of actual base or headquarters
mechanic were which is by the way set in
the White House you've taken over the
White House it's now yours and all your
allies are there and it's very similar
to the the main base in the division one
where you're gradually upgrading certain
sections of it and how that works in
Division two is that you know you're
actually recruiting all these uh people
from these different settlements around
Washington DC and some of those people
are actually you know really good to you
know keep around and you know you'll be
able to send them to the White House and
so they can sort of upgrade certain
areas of you know the base and then in
addition to that the settlements also
will start patrolling the map as you
increase their I can only assume is rank
yeah so you you help these elements then
you capture control points around the
map with their help by the way you can
you can fire off a flare and they'll
come help you
so there's real-world game mechanics
other than just the emotional hook of it
right um it seems like your allies
actually have more of a place in the
world and you know sort of an impact on
the world they I mean they can actually
help you like during fights and those
like sort of those uh control points are
actually you know I guess lead to some
of the more hectic battles because I'm
as you of course go through the campaign
and even towards the end game those of
those battles become more hectic and
more elites will come up like you know
then of course they will take advantage
of any weapons that are nearby there's
one control point where you know I guess
so we're struggling with where there's a
minigun there's a Construction Yard you
know they held that spot tight and you
know
guy had a minigun and it was it was it
was a tough flight also eventually got
on the minigun and did work for our side
which was cool yeah the mounted weapon
actually was really interesting and of
course them after you've secured that
control point you'll actually be able to
open up a supply closet which actually
houses a ton of loot so that's a good
point let's talk about loot yes delete
drop rates in the event that we played
felt good like it there was a constant
stream of loot now it was classic
division gold stuff isn't necessarily
the best stuff there were many times
where we fell back on purple items
because of handling of gold weapons yeah
but in general it feels like there's a
good reward system there's also a cash
system so you're constantly earning
points towards caches and those caches
then drop in your inventory and you can
open them up you know whenever you want
to and that was also a an update from in
the original division were you know
after the I guess the the main like 1.4
update which was basically just
overhauled much of the game and you know
it added those a I believe they're
called a field Pro proficiency caches
and they they really like incentivize
actually you know trying to do more
content in like more more missions and
you know other events to try to level up
so you can get just you know that box
so we played against these factions
these factions fight for power on the
map and then a new faction invades at
the end of the game so that's kind of
the that's the overall hook from what we
saw right now yeah there's some other
stuff too like safe houses give you
missions to clear areas of the map but
in general it feels like you have a much
bigger impact on the world in the first
game where you landed at Chelsea pier
and the people standing in line at
Chelsea pier were still standing there
at the end of the game like nothing had
changed at all which felt real bad yeah
and I feel like um you know even though
New York was a very like a visually
interesting place to visit there wasn't
actually all that much like you know in
terms of like you know growth
I mean you tore up that city yet it
didn't really seem like it what I
appreciate about this game is that it
shows more of an impact direct impact
rather of your actions like you know in
terms of like you know actually building
up bases establishing new settlements
and you know actually helping out other
characters that actually interact with
you you know you connect there's a
number of moments where you're actually
talking to other characters and you can
like read up more about them like you
know see what they're about you know as
usual I don't want to rose-color
everything in a game so there were some
things that didn't come across so well
in this build of the game yeah but it
was unusually dark the game like a
during the night in particular yeah not
not somatically dark here what's the
mattock Lee dark but it was like hard to
see hard to see yeah I group actually
asked one of the developers who was
hanging back and just watching us play
and and we thought it was maybe just our
televisions like we're you know this
just wasn't set correctly or when water
or whatever and he was like no no that's
that's that's what we're going for here
we all promptly cranked up the
brightness to maximum said yeah because
I was just shooting at health bars I
couldn't even say yes I'm like a it was
it was distracting like you know in
terms of just how difficult it was to
actually you know see some other things
I didn't particularly like the and and
to be honest the progression system is
probably only gonna buggy for an hour
and then it'll go away but there were
some weird things like you had to spend
your Tech on unlocking your second
weapon slot and and
locking attachments yeah which just
didn't feel right it felt like you
should be able to just pick those up and
go yeah this is for the the new I guess
sort of expanded version of The Perks
park system from the original game um
over the course of the game you'll
basically acquire these sort of sshd
tokens which you can spend on sort of
perks and one of the first perks you can
get is uh unlocking the second weapon
slots so you can carry like another like
you carry two primaries one sidearm and
of course after the campaign's finish
the one specialization weapon yeah and
some of your abilities that you spend it
on weren't that good and you could waste
the money on one of those rather than
knowing you had to use it to unlock your
second slot right a couple of the
abilities now require you to kind of
just haphazardly mash the bumper until
they sort of do what you think they
should do for example there was a bomber
drone and in those cases it was just
easier to shoot things than to waste
your time trying to figure out how many
times you had to mash a bumper to get it
to do what you wanted to do in the first
place that was also extra frustrating
when division does the monster closet
thing that you were talking about before
where some of the rooms were ridiculous
no yeah some of the rooms were fantastic
like the Air and Space Museum that level
was amazing it was perfect that it was
like look beautiful and then we did
another endgame mission called bunker
the the the federal emergency bunker and
we were just stuck in a room full of
closets with enemies spawning just
constantly yeah and the room just
flipped tons of different times to the
point where just wasn't fun anymore yeah
I'm actually looked in one of the doors
that opened up and it seemed like there
like two heavies you're sort of like
bunched up in like a room like you know
they're literally like just stuck in
there like a closet you know just like
you know just waiting for like the right
opportunity to come out and it was like
the most video-gaming moment I
experienced in the division like it just
kept going and going and this was like a
ten minute encounter this is by the way
this was an this is one of the invaded
missions you know which happens during
the endgame where the black tusk
basically replaces the existing faction
in a previous mission and you know so
basically they're throwing everything at
you like you know in this case like they
pretty much threw everything like it
seems like they threw almost every like
soldier they had in the Black toast
faction at us
they could still work on their their
enemy spawns yeah all right final
thoughts do you feel like the endgame is
there and is it going to hold on to you
after that 40-hour campaign when you
look at how the division one launched
with its endgame then definitely 100%
like theirs they're doing way more with
the endgame it feels more thoughtful in
terms of like you know how this uh this
new faction the black tusk basically
sort of disrupts everything of course
you're going to be going through a lot
of the I guess the usual missions you
went through but with the twist of the
new faction basically coming in and
disrupting like you know what you would
expect with those previous missions and
by the way they're also gonna randomize
the encounters you have within those
missions when you're doing the invaded
versions which is like be I guess the
elite version which is which only comes
up in the endgame so and of course when
you also add in like you know what
they're doing with the dark zones as
well like the occupied dark zones which
cycle every week those are the ones that
are not level balanced yes friendly fire
executive they're really adding a lot
more in terms of like you know just sort
of like shifting sort of the balance of
the world itself and of course this also
leads up into the eventual raid content
that will be coming into the game yeah a
player raids a player raids um that's a
big deal the division private beta is
coming out soon you'll pretty much be
able to play what we played so in
addition to I guess the first couple
hours you'll be able to play the two
versions of the endgame missions of
particularly the Air and Space Museum
and the federal emergency bunker and
also we've done a lot of coverage of the
three dark zones if you head on over to
GameSpot comm you can watch our full
impressions on their version of PvP
ve-be ppbe
alright thanks for watching everyone
Oh